so David Sachs who founder of Yammer put
out a beautiful post met our figures of
YouTube video that says how to build
your sales team he's like look I didn't
know this when I got into it we started
Yammer we thought we're gonna get this
Bottoms Up adoption then we need to make
money they didn't actually get
bottoms-up adoption but they didn't make
bottoms up revenue yeah that's a good
distinction and they've got the product
in and then they go to the CIO they're
like hey ever you know 20% of your
employees are using this don't you want
control over this and so then he just
walks there he's like look this thing
you don't need to be a genius like just
follow the playbook
don't try to deviate and invent your own
sales system with a playbook and so he
was so he walks through it on I remember
all the tough my head but if you've
watched it on YouTube he's like look
here's how you calculate your comp for
your salespeople here's how you
calculate your quotas there's these two
options you're either gonna go with this
path or this path depends on the price
your product and here's how you need to
think about it here's when you hire you
know sort of a sales manager and here's
what you have here's how you compensate
them and he literally just lays it out
and it's like oh this is if you're
somebody who's in that because you know
building your sales organization and you
kind of don't know what you're doing
just Google David sacks YouTube how to
build your sales team or whatever and
you'll find this YouTube video with like
100 views but I mean Sachs is the best
he's super smart on this and he's
obviously done it a bunch of times what
I think is interesting is you know Sam
what you said earlier like when we come
into companies one of the first things
we help them do is just triple prices
and that's the same thing if it's a 5k a
are are just they're a 5k a CD same
thing if it's a like you almost always
can price things significantly higher
than you think you can and generally the
companies we work with you want to see
them at a minimum like 25k ACV that's
like that if you're having if you have
25k accounts like that's 25,000 dollar
account rather that's where you're yeah
here that's where you start to see some
real leverage from going on a sales team
if you if you're a little song to that
it can be a little bit tough
[Music]
you